I'm gonna take full accountability for
that yeah but that's indicative of
somebody who's young though so I think
like you should yeah I shouldn't really
have I'm not saying I mean it's great
that you know you can look back at the
age of 15 or 16 and hold yourself
accountable for these things but for me
as it like I look back now and I gotta
say sometimes young people are just
young and it's just it just takes time
for somebody to mature you know and
that's the hard part because yeah that's
why we have a lot of old heads they
looked at a young people you're [ __ ]
done but if I know those people and I'm
like Don when you were younger you were
way worse you know so there was there
was something that happened in your life
that allowed you to mature whether it
was time where there was a human being
who knows what that was but those things
take steps in time to happen right so
yeah that mean there's accountability
that you should take for it but there's
also time where you were a kid yeah and
most 15 and 16 year olds they don't go
through what you went through you know
and that's that's the hard part too
that's why it's like I want I always
Wunderland somebody like in your case
like if you know who was in your corner
like that could really be like yo stop
or listen you know or some [ __ ] you know
I feel a lot of people you know the
label was yeah at times though because I
also do feel like respectively I don't
want to hear their business out that's
just not how I am but I will say I had
went through a lot of like hypocritical
confusion and again they were younger at
this point in time too and a lot of the
people that were in my corner were
younger it was a different time but it
was just certain things like you know
you got to work hard bro everybody you
got to steer your ship you got to be the
leader you got to be the leader of this
[ __ ] I'm 19 mind you I'm 18 19 the [ __ ]
do you mean Jeff this is like what the
[ __ ] like my friend just got his first
car like what the [ __ ] do you mean like
yeah weird to tell the kid that I look
at now like I have a I have somebody
around me at this moment mm-hmm he he's
part of my team shout out to Jack perros
his name's Jack and he's like soot he's
a super young kid but I never take him
like like I never try to Sun him like
that because of the amount of times I
felt like I was son it just really
really weirded me out at those times to
kind of be pressured into things and
talk to like I was a college football
player when I really was just a
like you know what I mean like so cute
like music yeah like that you know but
you know it's just I love you jack
sometimes and sometimes I'll feel a bit
all like speak a bit harsh to them and
then I'll even indicate it within my own
speech because of those times it's like
don't pressure him that much man yeah
dude like what are you doing man like
this is this is fun at the end of the
day with all of you yeah be a nicer guy
to this kid man
and like it you know with that being
said it's like I just
with those moments in in my life I just
wish there was somebody in my corner at
least to be like oh [ __ ] yeah you know
again for example that you know you
steer the ship all this stuff but then
being told again with what I said about
like hypocritical things it's like on
the other side I get amen
we need you to hang out with some kids
man being around a lot of older people
you know X&Y is he got friends from NYU
cuz I stayed over seeing in New York at
the time like I want you go hang out
with them you know and it's like I just
felt like like a studied lab rat at
certain points you know and it again
it's not what how I always say this it's
not about what people say it's how you
make them feel mmm and that's how I felt
I felt like a lab rat at certain point
because they will give you advice that
didn't even know what was it was sound
either they were just talking it's not
like they were just talking they're just
like uh maybe he should do this but they
were singing with a lot of comedy yeah
even though they didn't really know and
again they didn't so that's I'm not like
they're horrible people it's not like
that it was it was a lot of stuff I mean
I got talked to a certain way a lot and
and I know that because I go to therapy
now and I'm telling my therapist all
this stuff and she's like looking at me
like you know what I mean like how it's
like I know it's certain things weren't
all the way my fault you know but I took
accountability anyway as a kid and then
beat myself up for it a lot and I given
with a lot of I grew with a lot of
self-hate I grew with a lot of shame and
then when things went a little sour I
grew with even more shame mmm
and it was you know the people in my
corner
they did help me out and they were quite
confident but I feel like the love
language just was a bit harsh I feel
like you know one of the last sorry one
of the last meetings I had with them was
just this meeting of you know things
aren't going well I think you're gonna
need to take a trip back to Toronto and
be a kid again and kind of make some
decisions and you know and and finally
but it was like it was like almost the
cage had been set free then the canary
can go mm-hmm and I'm like it's I am 21
what yeah what yeah like what are you
talking about like yeah like my young
life is just beginning but what yeah and
then it was just weird and or 20 21 I
don't even need to date these things at
this point but that's what happened
and again like hearing I funny enough I
found out later on in my life that
during that whole period of time I was
anxious that anxiety rough anxiety yeah
very weird anxiety like I would
literally like ask anybody around that
like I I'd like I mean it weirdly enough
I'm not doing it right now but I would
just be jittery in rooms and and at a
certain point in time it's like even you
know for example the people in my corner
I would shake and they'd be like help
stop [ __ ] shakin man yo see Nene one
successful person that shakes mm-hmm
it's just like that it's like you could
kindly tell me to stop shaking but on
this child star you want some you know I
mean and it's like it's not [ __ ]
shaking or like somebody would record me
doing it and then send it to the group
chat and I'd have to see you know what I
mean like just dumb [ __ ] and again I
don't want to be disrespectful II airing
anybody out but just to show you
perspective on how I felt back then it
was very weird you know very like very
just a lot of that stuff didn't need to
be said to me but at the same time I
don't feel like the world owes me [ __ ]
and I don't feel like it's like the
world is the world's going to be mean
sometimes so that's that's another thing
I kind of had to learn out all that and
I kind of have to learn to build my
thick skin and and really understand
these situations for what they are and
it's weird because you're kind of thrown
into a very harsh
a very harsh industry though especially
as a young star right and I think like
with with companies like that they kind
of look at people like products right
yeah so when they see you do things that
are actually very [ __ ] human you know
they're yeah and in a way though again
like I'd have to come from a place of
understanding too it's like they were
family to me at a certain point so I can
never ever sit here and say and and and
victimize myself I can't victimize
myself no I always tell myself that like
don't do that like you went through
things they went through things and it's
it's it's that's what it is and it's all
the past so no lay it down but also just
be aware of what happened and and
reflect upon these feelings sometimes
because at a certain point in time I'm
going to have either an artist under me
saw an entity under me somebody like
Jack that I was talking about earlier
you know that somebody that I'm going to
have to play that role with sometimes
not a big brother per se but probably
just a mentor I guess in certain ways I
think were you to though like like I
understand the whole concept of not
wanting to like victimize yourself and
taking personal responsibility but
there's a point where it kind of goes a
little too much right where you kind of
hold this thing where it becomes too
much your fault you know so there's like
a really tricky balance of that yeah
because you know if because we could
talk about personal responsibility and
we could tell ourselves all the time
it's like I understand that's how the
world is but sometimes people are just
[ __ ] up yeah yeah and so I think it's
so because I'm more the opposite side
right guys go [ __ ] you have mental
clarity after that and you know probably
my side I'm probably a little bit more
opposite of you where there's I do take
a lot of personal responsibility for the
things that I do but when people [ __ ] up
around me I do have a tendency to hold
it against them a lot yeah in the sense
that it's like it's not that sense I
don't have empathy empathy for them
right so for example like you know I
have friends who have done [ __ ] up
things but then I look back at them I
could be like oh well they had a pretty
[ __ ] up life growing up people I trade
them they've stabbed them in the back
and they're just putting that energy on
me but I still say that the other day
[ __ ] you though so I try to balance it
out a little bit like I understand you
as a person I'll [ __ ] with you anymore
yeah you know with the people in my
corner from back then it's like we're
cordial now of course you know things
are civil now
and I love that I love that it's not for
us everybody said sorry to each other
everybody has paid their respects to
each other but at the end of the day as
well you know there's there are certain
things I don't forget mm-hmm and there
were certain moments you know in those
times that embedded into my personality
in a bad way and I'd like to be aware of
that and I'd like to of course gradually
change that over because you absorbed a
lot of that as a young person yeah I
feel like sometimes it leaks out yeah
definitely
especially in the way I talk my demeanor
certain things I that I do I always go
home and I reflect but not over think I
just reflect so you know I even tonight
like from certain things that I said
maybe I'll just reflect upon them you
know and and just hope that I didn't
hurt anybody and with what I said cuz I
never want to do that now I never want
to actually come out my neck about
anybody that that serviced me whether
bad are good because what with whatever
you did I am me now because of it so I
can't you know what I mean I can't be
bitter like that I grew up with a lot of
a lot of hate on my shoulder you know
walking into walking into certain things
you know I didn't grow up with a father
you know I grew up with a stepdad and I
and I loved him you know what I mean
like I could grow with certain feelings
but at the same time like I'm growing to
appreciate you know what I mean yeah but
I have been through certain things in my
life that just that put hate in my heart
what age did your dead dad leave three
or four I think no super young so you
know did you not really have a
relationship with him work nah I don't
even really know what he looks like
oh really yeah like I don't really know
him like that um one of the last times I
heard of and I'm just gonna say this
because I can't say it and whatever it's
my life yeah people could take it out
they want but one of the last things I
heard from him or about him was he
wanted forgiveness from me or something
mm-hmm and I just couldn't really I
don't really have like a like it like
you know what to say it's just like cool
you know yeah like I get it but like who
are you to me anyway
because I love my stepdad yes more than
anything in the world so it's like yeah
if it was my stepdad sorry if it was my
stepdad and I that I had
and he was on some [ __ ] like that you
know after some time by all means cuz
you have a foundation hell yeah like my
stepdad is the [ __ ] he's the greatest
person in the world to me like I love
him and I idolized him so it's hard so
when he asked for forgiveness I I don't
even know ya know what am I supposed to
say he's not me being bitter like a lot
of people take it as like a bitter thing
I just take it as like I don't know you
know I cuz even if you said the word
like you don't know if you mean it or
not just like I guess I forgive you but
forgive what like I don't know who you
are yeah but you know I again like
certain that I don't have hate in my
heart for him like he made me yeah it is
what it is you know but at the same time
like I just don't know you so it is what
it is but I you know is that that right
that one of those situations in my life
like that's the situation in my life I
could look back and be like okay that
you know that was one of the chips on my
shoulder walking into life mm-hmm you
know I had a lot of them but I think now
I feel I'm going through somewhat of a
resurgence so